four days from now the voters here in
New Hampshire will weigh in seven
Democratic hopefuls head to head to the
hope to convince New Hampshire to vote
for them in Tuesday's primary the debate
started with messages of unity in the
matter who wins this damn thing we're
all gonna stand together to the people
but it didn't take long for the
presidential hopefuls to start trading
barbs 38 year-old Peter Budaj edge was
singled out for his perceived lack of
experience he was ready for the
criticism if you're looking for the
person with the most years of Washington
establishment experience under their
belt
you've got your candidate and of course
it's not me the perspective I'm bringing
is that of somebody whose life has been
shaped by the decisions that are made in
those big white buildings in Washington
DC and when Sanders addressed social
welfare issues you raised the minimum
wage to 15 bucks an hour we're not gonna
give tax breaks to billionaires former
Vice President Joe Biden questioned
where the money would come from it will
cost more than the entire the entire
federal budget we spend now when
questioned on the impeachment
proceedings Biden prompted a standing
ovation for Colonel Alexander bin Minh a
key witness to the trial and fired by
Trump stand up and clap for amendment
[Applause]
what
for a lot of these candidates New
Hampshire's do-or-die
if club Bashar doesn't break into the
top four here she's out of this race if
Warren finishes a distant third again
she's in very bad shape and if Biden
isn't very close to the topic he's
really reeling on foreign policy but
Rajesh was asked if he would make the
same decision as Trump in killing the
Iranian general Qasem Soleimani
in Iran we learned nothing else from the
war in Iraq it's the taking out a bad
guy is not a good idea if you do not
know what you were doing you cannot go
around saying you're a bad guy we're
gonna assassinate you and then you're
gonna have if that happens you're
opening the door to international
advocate Tuesday's primary could very
well decide on who stays in the race
this was an opportunity for the hopefuls
to make their case with Sanders imbrue
tgh seen as the ones to beat Laura
Burton Manley Al Jazeera